[Music]
on this episode of travel care I'm
taking Caroline to hop in the spa we're
gonna soak in a tub full of beer and I'm
having Joe try some daring flavors at
one of Portland's most famous ice-cream
shops come join us on our adventures on
this episode of Travel dares
welcome to travel I'm Joe and I'm
Caroline today we are in Portland Oregon
Portland is known for its amazing food
and crafts fierce and beautiful hikes
Portland's unofficial slogan is keep
Portland weird and we're here to explore
the weirdest parts of the city all right
Caroline ready for your clue ready all
right something's brewing okay I think I
have an idea of what this will be oh do
you yes yes I'm excited I have a pretty
good guess that we are going to a
brewery we are going to make some beer
Caroline thinks we're going to a brewery
but little does she know we're going to
America's first beer spa Carol I can do
me a favor and just dip your hand down
to the right oh wait sounds like oats or
something all right Caroline take off
your blindfold cuz today we're soaking
in a tub full of beer no way
one of the reasons that you know Sisters
Oregon where we're from is just such a
perfect place as its you know the
Northwest is the hop capital of the
world Central Oregon is the craft brew
capital of the world
we source our hops from a variety of
suppliers our primary supplier have been
Crosby farms and over in the Willamette
Valley hops is an herb it has some
anti-inflammatory properties and some
analgesic properties it's great for the
skin it's great for psoriasis and eczema
[Music]
how does it feel soaking in a tub of
beer this is so fun this is like a good
hot soak but the hops kind of feel like
a good exfoliant on your body which I'm
always a fan of so this is really
enjoyable I want to do something that
combined our two favorite things you
love spas and I love beer it smells so
good and I am just it's a strange
feeling for your body to be soaking in
all these hops but it's something that
like I'm getting used to I've definitely
never had a spa experience like this
before Joe and that was so much fun but
now it's your turn
oh boy prepare to be chilled to the bone
oh no are we going to a haunted house
I'm gonna be chilled to the bone
maybe I'm getting x-rayed I don't know
this is a very cryptic clue
now Joseph adventurous eater but I think
these ice cream flavors are gonna be
unlike anything he's tried before so I'm
just gonna have you hold this take it up
to your face and take a taste your
blindfold Joe we are at salt & straw and
we are going to be making three bizarre
flavors of ice cream today really yes
[Music]
that's Alton's try I think we've come up
with them just over 500 flavors we're
constantly testing and trying out new
recipes when we're talking about a
bone-marrow ice cream I think like that
one in particular is so fun because
we've got some of the best recruiter
ease and butcher shops in the country
here in Portland and then also we've got
these organ cherries that are just so
dark and rich oh yeah that is so
satisfying our edible bug flavor creepy
crawly critters is so fun so being able
to put that in a grassy ice cream like a
matcha ice cream almost makes you feel
like you're laying on like a grassy
field and the bugs are crawling up your
arm mmm crunchy you might taste the
thorax
peanut butter this world that's gonna go
in our pickle ice cream
[Music]
we've got a pickle ice cream that we're
working on the pickles are so intensely
fresh and like tart and just made so
much sense to start integrating them in
a cream and sugar pickles are disgusting
I don't like them I don't eat them that
an ice cream that nothing I don't know
about this I really don't think he's
gonna try the pickle one which is the
one I was really excited for we'll see
let's get to it I would like to start
with the cherry and bone marrow oh it's
really good you can taste the smokiness
of the bone marrow and have really Oh
with the cherries absolutely incredible
I have an announcement to make mint
chocolate chip over some bugs and matcha
we are now going to the pickled ice
cream dun dun dun dun must you all right
here we go pickles and peanut butter
[Music]
I mean here's what I like about it the
peanut butter is great and it does a
really good job of masking the taste of
pickles that being said I don't hate it
trying something new I'm not the biggest
pickle fan I think this is pretty good
but imagine if someone who loves pickles
this is your ice cream do you thing your
pickle loving scale went up after this
ice cream yeah I'm a little more
tolerant pickles after this I always
stick to the plastic like chocolate
vanilla caramel and this is unlike
anything I've tried before all right Joe
went to the beer spa that you picked out
yep what's my rating Caroline getting in
a big tub of beer certainly is weird you
know you seemed a bit apprehensive
getting in there and a little grossed
out by the house but after a while you
got into it I notice you started
relaxing you tried hard 37 5 I mean I
guess that's fair all right Caroline
what's my rating okay so when we went
into salt & straw I didn't know you'd
have so much fun making the ice cream
and then when we actually got to try it
you loved the bone marrow you loved the
bug ice cream not so keen on the pickles
but you still tried it and for those
reasons you're getting a four out of
five or peat baby I love it Joe
traveling is all about trying new things
and we tried the beer spa and we tried
three unique flavors of ice cream so I
really think we made the most of
Portland this has been an amazing trip
to the west coast
next stop Key West
you